introduction of human test subjects we
can now confirm the taifa as a complex
ecosystem of alien species each with
their own specialized role each an
opportunity for product ization but our
understanding is limited and we
hypothesized there are other type and
species yet to be discovered the core of
our research is the typhoon Kaka plasma
the progenitor of the entire type-in
ecosystem nicknamed for its unique
polymorphic ability and mimic imitate
inanimate objects of similar mass
concealing itself to ambush prey our
team has already submitted several
proposals to product development for
potential neural mod application of
course of the armaments concepts group
we engaged in field observations of the
dangerous combat abilities of typhoon
anthro phantasmal or phantom spawned by
the Weaver species the phantom is hybrid
of Taif and DNA and a human corpse Manta
may exhibit human-like neural patterns
but it is in no way human in close
quarters of phantoms polymorphic limbs
are deadly at range
phantoms attacked with spheres of
kinetic energy that detonate on empower
a species known as the telepath is
considered one of the most dangerous
known - for its unprecedented psychic
abilities the telepath uses powerful
psychic energy to control weaker willed
organism personal known wave devices are
recommended in the event of psychic
Sheila William this represents our third
quarter findings and concludes the
current types of research
[Music]